le charbon sort il sort pour l'industrie
il investit voici le quotidien et
privant d'un mineur du nord de la france
en 1945
à l'époque les gueules noires creuse
pioche est extrait des tonnes de charbon
un temps aujourd'hui révolue depuis le
milieu des années 90 le bassin minier du
nord pas de calais s'est transformée
devenant une région prisée des touristes
attention c'est parti 1945 la france est
affaiblie par la guerre pour pallier la
pénurie d'électricité et redresser le
pays une solution extraire un maximum de
charbon le plus rapidement possible la
production journalière était de 4 depuis
l'aube à rome mais par deux gros 44 et
mon pays en juillet à 85 ans plus les
années passent et moins l'activité
devient rentable
en cause notamment moins de charbon à
extraire mais aussi la concurrence du
pétrole et du gaz les usines ferment
une situation dénoncée par ce mineur
nous demandons qu est-ce qui va
remplacer les mêmes parce qu'une mène
alors que la dette soit 800 900 bonhomme
tu as dès que vous avez des usines qui
est 70 bonhomme l'exploitation
charbonnière du bassin minier se termine
en 1990 cette année là la dernière
gaillette de charbon est remonté à
oignies dans le pas de calais
un événement suivi en direct à la
télévision voilà donc les derniers
mineurs qui remonte de 780 mètres de
fond pour la dernière fois avec cette
fermeture
terminées les usines et les puits de
charbon dès lors une question se pose
que faire de ces sites laissés à
l'abandon
en 1997 la commune de noeux les mines
avait trouvé une solution construire une
piste de ski artificielle sur l'étang
d'un ancien terril ces collines composer
le charbon ça glisse très bien sa part
des gags en 2002 l'association du bassin
minier uni veut aller plus loin
à sa tête jean françois caron maire de
loos en gohelle dans le pas de calais
l'objectif classer l'ensemble du
territoire au patrimoine mondial de
l'unesco
un devoir de mémoire selon l'un des
porteurs du projet pense que cela nous
amènera beaucoup de facilité on ne veut
pas être oublié le bassin minier classé
à l'unesco
c'est chose faite en 2012 87 communes 51
terry 28 écoles ou encore 4000 hectares
de paysages sont notamment distingués
grâce à cette reconnaissance mondiale
c'est toute une région qui est mise en
valeur résultat les touristes affluent
comme ici où centre historique minier de
lewarde en 2013 c'est notre patrimoine
on se doit de venir voir dans quelles
conditions travaillent et le potentiel
le centre historique minier de lewarde
et le plus important musée de la mine en
france cette ancienne fosse fermé en
1971 accueille chaque année près de 150
mille visiteurs
[Musique]